thank you alejandro we are indeed with
the dominant victor of the round richie
rapport richie welcome to the studio
tell us your first impressions of poland
and the rapidem blitz
uh yeah i have been to poland already
and i have been playing rapid emblems in
poland so you know
not much has changed in this regard oh
it's a new event and it's going uh well
i mean
from an organization point of view from
my play point of view it's going okay i
guess 50 in the first uh day how would
you assess that
i guess i had two blocks i would uh say
it's okay but uh of course uh
i had probably more in my games but it's
no more result yeah last game i lost
kind of stupidly um so obviously that
was not so satisfying but um other than
that okay this is rocket so if anything
goes in today you chose this uh e4
followed by uh d3 king's indian attack
sort of set up how did you approach
today's game did you wanted to go out
and uh play a long game make him think
how did you approach it yeah i usually
play like this in in
the rapid blitz i was spoiled for my
next opponents yeah so it's not
obviously in the most principled move
but okay i
i guess i like or maybe not i don't like
because white is i think almost uh
always even worse in these positions but
i feel like with shorter time controls
uh maybe it can get um
slightly difficult to play as black and
i think this is what happened in the
game and there was this maneuvering
phase
what would you say the critical moments
yeah i mean i was like when he played b5
okay yeah this is completely normal
normal stuff standard stuff and then
yeah so it was
yeah this [ __ ] is a mistake obviously
because um
structure i think he forgot that i can
play c3 because it would be a little
slightly different story if he was
forced to capture but after c3
96 abm just clearly better he has no
squares and so the idea being that if
you take take now c3 yeah this is not
yeah i mean it still is completely fine
of course but not as bad as the game was
for him yeah and after the next one was
yeah i tried to then go for this idea
with g4 which i did in the game and
probably an expert moment was when he
played d4
i think after d4 um
yeah like i think here like
like i am just clearly better in after
94 and dc it's a bit uh absurd because
he hasn't passed pawn and i have double
pawns but uh i have bishop pair and
my uh
strange structure is you know kind of
dominating his knights so he has no
squares
and then i you know ended up getting a
mid-attack after that he went uh for a
walk his king went for uh a walk oh nice
somewhere around here and he went king
to e8 and it felt like maybe he's hiding
but how did you assess the position at
this point are you sure that you were
winning pretty much yeah i mean i am
maybe done upon for a while but okay i'm
taking it on a5 so basically it's equal
material i have bishop where i have a
pawn on it's heaven almost which i'm
promoting and his king is totally
exposed and i have no virtual weaknesses
here so i mean i wasn't too skeptical
it's just very awkward position so
uh maybe it could be a little bit
confusing but i was not
adopting too much that you know i should
be the one who is um
calling the shot sort of yeah richie
you're playing uh fabiano caruana with
the black pieces in just uh 10 minutes
preface that game for us
yeah
no idea i like to play fabian so we'll
see
it'll be fun that's for sure definitely
having our eyes on that thank you very
much richie and good luck in the next
game and we will be going on a break
stay tuned we'll be coming back shortly
[Music]